hi everyone sal here with my
three-year-old son azad and we're
excited to announce the launch of khan
academy kids which is designed to take
students like azad ages two to five to
become lifelong learners hi friends
welcome to my room kids love this
program because it's really fun
friendly characters like our narrator
cody bear welcome to khan academy kids
interact with them throughout the
learning experience and we've combined
tasks like math and reading with
activities like drawing and storytelling
we really think parents and teachers are
going to love khan academy kids because
it's aligned with important standards
like the common core and the head starts
learning outcomes framework there are
thousands of activities in original
books in the program khan academy kids
also promotes social emotional
development through topics like empathy
and sharing and what's more we've
partnered with super simple songs
bellwether media and national geographic
young explorer magazine to provide
learning materials kids will love khan
academy kids is a free mobile app
available in the app store google play
and amazon download today and let the
joyful learning begin
[Music]
hi everyone sal here i'm here to
announce
hi everyone i'm here with my son azad
who's three years old to announce the
launch of khan academy kids which is
designed
to get students aged two to five ready
to become learners for life
yes it loud and funny
[Music]
download today and let the joyful
learning begin
how do they do this in movies